thank you very much Stephen I was going
to say senator Thurmond who was here
earlier today and pay a special tribute
to a strong who in fact dropped into
Normandy so many years ago deputy
secretary hamri general Shelton mrs.
Shelton Admiral Johnson and mrs. Johnson
officers the Armed Forces Janet and
ladies and gentlemen I'd like to begin
with a quote from Euripides one of the
great Greek tragedy ins he asked in one
of his plays he said how do i praise
thee and not over praise yet marthae
grace by stint thereof it's a challenge
to praise a man who's won nearly as many
awards as we have forces deployed well
at least as many peacekeepers as we have
in this in the Sinai and in Haiti Oliver
Wendell Holmes senior who was the father
of one of our greatest Supreme Court
justices he wrote that the first thing
naturally when one enters a scholars
study or library is to look at his books
one gets a notion very speedily of his
tastes and the range of his pursuits by
a glance at his bookshelves well if we
substitute the words films made for
books read then we take the mark of
Steven Spielberg rather quickly he has
the wonderful multicolored imagination
of a child wear fancy can take
futuristic flight on gossamer wings as
it did in et or descend into the
terrifying phobias of poltergeist or
jaws or Jurassic Park but for me at
least what displays the range of his
mind is his fascination not only with
where we can go rocketing into the
future but where we've been in
canvassing are painful past and here we
point to Amistad the color purple
Schindler's List and it's his respect
for our history the articulate audible
and visual voice that he gives to our
experience at a time when so much of its
substance is being erased by the PCs
Delete key that eliminates his soul he
is determined through his art and
through his philanthropic works to help
America avoid the fate of Robert Frost
hired man who had nothing to look
backward to with pride and nothing to
look forward to with hope which brings
me to the reason why we're all here
today and that is to express the Defense
Department's gratitude for what this
visionary liberal / conservative i could
say compassionate conservative but that
would be wrong what he has done for the
men and women who have worn our nation's
uniform and who wear it today who were
and are prepared to rappel into the hell
of war and for so many into an i elation
itself for cause greater than self it
was just about a year ago today that
Jack valetti a decorated World War two
veteran who had 51 flights who along
with Strom Thurmond as a member of Tom
Brokaw's greatest generation but Jack
invited Janet me to a private screening
of Saving Private Ryan and when the last
of the credits rolled the lights came up
almost everybody in the theater that
evening had tears in their eyes others
were so stunned they could not speak
most wouldn't make eye contact with one
another all we could hear were the
sounds of silence everyone simply wanted
to leave the theater so we could go home
and reflect on the meaning and on the
power of that film and then some weeks
later when the army paid tribute to
Steven the eloquence of his words
they're only added to the force of his
message and he spoke very movingly about
how he wanted to make this movie as a
way of saying thank you thank you to his
father who had served a border be 25
during World War two and thank you to
his father's generation for their
service and sacrifice during that war
well we are here today in turn to say
thank you for what you have given all of
us I think one of the most remarkable
results of that film was not
only that it prompted us to go back into
the past but that it prompted so many of
the veterans to come forward because for
decades many of the veterans struggled
to find the right words the right way to
share with family and friends what they
had suffered through during that war but
over the past year we have heard so many
stories of veterans who after seeing
this film finally venturing forth to
tell a son a daughter or grandchild of
their experience and so this film has
not only provided an emotional catharsis
for yesterday's veterans but a reminder
to today's soldiers that the gift
outright was many deeds at war that
blood and bone and soul soul were
sacrificed so that a mechanized evil in
Europe would not triumph and stamp out
the fires of freedom Ryan I must be
quick to point out is not a recruitment
promotional for the Pentagon it speak to
us however about the importance of
values of discipline of determination
and of sacrifice and forces us to
confront those unsettling existential
questions that go to the very marrow of
what it means to be an American is our
generation worthy of the sacrifices of
our forefathers are we upholding their
legacy what is the price of freedom are
we willing to pay the price and if so
how high well there was a book I read
some years ago which remains one of my
favorites was written by Alastair Cook
wrote a book called America and in one
of his chapters he made the inevitable
comparison between America and Rome and
he suggested that we like Rome were in
danger of losing that which we profess
to cherish most that Liberty is the
luxury of self-discipline and that those
nations who have failed to impose
discipline upon themselves have had it
imposed upon them by others and then he
said America is a country in which I see
the most persistent idealism and the
blandest of cynicism the most persistent
idealism and the blandest of cynicism
and the race is on between its vitality
and its decadence
and then he went on to paraphrase
Benjamin Franklin and he said we have a
great country and we can keep it but
only if we care to keep it ladies and
gentlemen you look out into the faces in
this audience if you look at the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs general
Shelton as you look at Admiral Johnson
you look at the faces of the men and
women who are serving in our military
today and the third 23,000 who come to
work here every day in the 1.2 million
plus who wear the uniform every day of
the year then you know that the race is
being won by our vitality and not our
decadence and is because of people like
Steven Spielberg who remind us of the
duty that we have to carry forward who
reminds us that we have a great country
and that we can keep it but only if we
care to keep it and so for that Steven I
want to say thank you on behalf of all
of us who care so much about this
country and want to see that the legacy
that we have inherited is passed on to
those who will follow us and that the
fires of freedom will continue to burn
and with the people who we represent
will carry forth the the same pride the
same commitment with the same sacrifice
of our forefathers and now if you'll
please read the citation
ladies and gentlemen please remain
seated during the presentation of this
award thank you to mr. Steven Spielberg
for exceptionally distinguished public
service as director of the movie Saving
Private Ryan and his significant
contributions to the nation and the
Department of Defense through his
masterpiece mr. Spielberg poignant Li
captured the stirring sacrifices of
America's World War two heroes and paid
moving tribute to their indomitable
fighting spirit in so doing he made in
historic contribution to the national
consciousness reminding all Americans
that the legacy of freedom and joy today
endures in great measure because of
their selfless and courageous actions
moreover mr. Spielberg helped to
reconnect the American public with its
military men and women while rekindling
a deep sense of gratitude for the daily
sacrifices they make on the frontlines
of our nation's defense the distinctive
accomplishments of mr. Spielberg reflect
great credit upon himself the Department
of Defense and the nation it gives me
great pleasure to present steven
spielberg the department of defense
medal for distinguished public service
signed william s cohen secretary of
defense
thank you very much mr. secretary uh mr.
chairman I'm in the Army now that's for
sure I think that if every American
could renew their vows with America as
I've had through the working privilege
of making Saving Private Ryan they could
feel a pride in their country that right
now fills my heart and soul and makes me
humble and I think will make my word
short it doesn't happen very often when
a filmmaker achieves his goals my goal
was to remember unsparingly the
sacrifices of my father's generation and
to try to get my children's generation
to honor the past and to understand the
importance of what World War two did for
all of us and did for the world I feel
that in my experience as a filmmaker
lightning has only struck twice in a way
that has filled me up with such pride
one of those times was Schindler's List
and the other time was saving private
ryan and i think that what I have
devoted myself to over the last several
years is just the act of remembrance and
the act of trying to lead others to
remember back along with me it's very
easy as we move into the next thousand
years to forget the last thousand it's
very easy to forget the last ten and I
think that today's youth have a tendency
to live in the present and work for the
future but to totally be ignorant of the
past and I just hope that through films
and through literature and through
television and through people who are
conscious of our vanishing history that
we will all do more to point people
backwards so we can take that giant leap
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
this concludes our ceremony please
remain standing for the departure of the
official party thank you
you